hi everyone I'm Marcel doing it and I'm
now giving the presentation this morning
welcome everyone and thank you for
attending so I'm from the garvan
institute and I'm presenting today are
lighting up the dark matter of the
genome are we working okay so we'll move
on to the first slide Ginny you there
yeah I advanced it and it says sorry an
error occurred please try again so I
click it off
it just give me one second please we're
just restarting oh we can do the limit
let me be very guide for defending a
small technical problem we have okay how
we doing out I can see myself now
I can see my slides yeah and they're
progressing now without an arrow okay
thanks okay let's try that again folks
I'm sorry about the small technical
problem there this is Marcel thing is
speaking from Sydney Australia we're
going to talk today about lighting up
the dark matter of the genome and
revelling non-coding DNA and disease and
development so as many will have recall
it was a long time to go back in the
1990s when genius that's worth first
well first were first time to be
estimated and it was it was understood
initially through DNA and RNA
hybridization experiments that were
between sort of 30 and 40 thousand or so
human genes then later on as they as
we're experiments done to calculate the
overall size of the genome it was worked
out that the human genome was in the
ballpark around about three Giga bases
so assuming a rough calculation of 30 kb
per gene which was the approximate size
from the small number of genes that had
been sequenced at that time that there
may be a hundred thousand genes it
followed on from there that the using
CPG Island density which predict
promoters that were about 80 thousand
genes and then EST sequencing and
commenced in full stream in the mid-90s
and they came up with a gene estimates
of around about 88,000 genes and then
from there in early 2000s when the human
genome was being sequenced it became
clear that that there were many
estimates that range vary widely from
27,000 to 150,000 with an average of
around 75,000 of course it's all ancient
history now but when the human genome
was finally published and annotated in
2003 the numbers first came in at about
24 and a half thousand later to around
about a very surprisingly low well below
anyone's estimate of around 20,000 this
seemed a huge paradox in a tremendous a
surprise to everyone for the reason that
has further genomes were sequenced
including mouse and in C elegans that we
all seem to have similar
numbers of protein-coding genes across
the entire pretty much the whole animal
kingdom then we look to other organisms
by Paramecium and and the sponge and
they actually had more genes than we did
it's with some surprise now later on a
few years later whole genome tiling
arrays and large-scale see DNA
sequencing will start to be undertaken
and this this changed the picture
someone because all this non-coding DNA
that was across in these genomes seem to
in fact be expressed so we came in with
the theory that perhaps the additional
complexity and the vastly greater number
of cell types that were present and
mammals could perhaps be reconciliate
'add by the expression and use of
non-coding RNAs so non-coding RNA seemed
to be recognized increasingly as key
components of the regulatory
architecture of complex organisms so
there are many examples of the snowin so
this wasn't an enormously revolutionary
in itself so in 1992 exist was
identified which compensates for the
dosage of the X chromosome by silencing
the expres measurement females and
similarly the air recruits the histone
methyltransferase to silence genes in
there igf to our locust during early
development and further more and more
non-coding RNAs were identified on a
sort of a one-by-one basis which seemed
to have a variety of different functions
so just how many long non-coding is
either encoded in the mammalian genome
so it turns out that most of the of
their genome is actually transcribed as
non-coding RNAs so our original
conception of of the genome where we had
jeans sort of scattered as islands in an
ocean of DNA with the extent of
occasional gene every few hundred kb
seem to have changed considerably once
RNA sequencing started in earnest so for
example we now see that if we look to
the genome browser that in fact when we
look at a protein coding gene we see it
enshrouded by a cloud of non-coding rnas
and non-coding transcripts so this was
shown initially by large Kelsey DNA
sequencing and then later was
substantiated by tiling arrays
so there was an initial idea that
perhaps these things were artifacts of
of transcription and what was what was
really going on there so what happens
later is that we then started the
sequence more and more and more of these
this this type of of these RNAs and
start to understanding more about its
function if we look now to encode we
actually see that there's a dramatic
increase in the number of of non-coding
RNAs that are actually annotated in the
human genome so at the moment if the
gencode records approximately 15,000
transcripts so the question then became
is what extent of these things actually
functional so long non-coding RNA when I
came in in the early 2000s was to
examine the expression of these using
non coding gene expression arrays this
may seem like an ancient technology now
but but today this seems to be a very
very effective approach for at the time
at least was a very effective approach
for essaying gene expression we use
these arrays to look at long non-coding
RNA expression and a huge number of
disease systems and developmental
systems so perhaps the most iconic of
these experiments was was was worth
looking at embryonic stem cell
differentiation so what we did was look
at a 16-day time course of embryonic
stem cells and what you can see in the
top panel those genes that associate
with with different with different
markers of pluripotency such as act 4 in
the middle with primitive streak
formations such as brekkie URI and meeza
we needed organ formation which is
marked by IDF so when we look at rnase
that cluster with these non-coding rnas
we can see that that we actually end up
without a large number of non-coding
RNAs that that cluster was the same
programs so this gave us the the first
clue really that these non-coding RNAs
may actually have a functional role
rather than just being a consequence of
spurious transcription we looked at a
very large number of these different
transcripts over
over a period of time and it became
clear that actually hundreds or perhaps
even thousands of these were functional
in a diversity of different cell systems
what was perhaps most notable about
these different studies that we
undertook in this time was was not just
the different non-coding RNAs that we
identified that were relevant in
different contexts but perhaps more
specifically that that every one of
these different systems expressed two
different Suites of long non-coding RNAs
in different stages of development we
would expect this it's led to the idea
that we would then also expect that long
non-coding RNAs should also be
necessarily expressed in a spatially
specific pattern so in 2007 using the
genome-wide atlas of of gene expression
in the mouse brain that was performed by
the Ellen Brain Institute we were
actually able to look at the expression
of long non-coding RNAs in front of
tissue-specific expression point of view
so in essence for those of you not
familiar with the study is that
essentially what they did is they take
mouse brains and they're sliced and
diced eventually endorse Lee and then
using in situ hybridization you could
examine the expression in with in 3d
space of of transcripts in the mouse
brain now the initial idea of this study
was in fact to look at this effect to
look at long non-coding RNAs what
service to look at messenger RNAs
however the the the the pools that they
used came from sort from much larger
cDNA libraries and when we investigated
these libraries we actually found that
about a thousand of them contained
non-coding RNAs so this was tremendously
interesting to us and gave us a huge
opportunity to actually investigate
expression of long non-coding RNAs using
this really quite spectacular technology
so it does indeed turn out that our
hypothesis was right that non-coding
RNAs are also expressed in the various
tissue-specific manner in tissues so
these are just a few examples of rnase
and for example the hippocampus and in
the heat map below you can see so
from BC and D will come up there you go
you can see expression there are
specifically in the dentate gyrus the
ca1 region and here co-expression in the
ca1 and dentate diarrhea region
similarly if we look at the expression
of long non-coding RNAs in the
cerebellum we see similar patterns where
again for almost every non-coding RNA
were able to identify very specific
locations where non-coding RNAs were
expressed so for example here in the
granular and molecular layers of the
cerebellum we're able to delineate
almost every single tissue type and cell
type in the brain by a different long
non-coding RNA and in fact when we go
further and look at the subcellular
localization of long non-coding RNAs
such as in purkinje cells which were
large enough to be able to actually
resolve some some degree of subcellular
t we also see remarkable patterns of
expressions for example rnase their
specific to the soma the nucleus some
that are expressed in twin fossa and
others that are expressed in multiple
fossa and finally as well in your rights
so together this information seemed to
seem to really be it's certainly very
contrary to suggestions that long
non-coding RNAs simply spurious or
unstable transcripts especially because
of the fact that they could be detected
by and situation which really gave us
the idea that wait a minute this idea
that these that non-coding RNAs should
be just expressed randomly and I just
quickly broken down them seem to be
right however at the time there was
absolutely no documentation or there was
no no reports at all on on the stability
of non-coding RNAs so this is the next
investigation that we undertook so it so
to do this again we used microarrays to
examine the stability of long non-coding
RNAs and now stir o blessed owner sells
so the experiment was reasonably
straightforward we tech neuroblastoma
cells and we inhibit expression of
oratory odors inhibit RNA polymerase 2
with xtina my sandy and then we just
take samples over a 32-hour time course
and effectively from this were able to
calculate the half-life is of these
non-coding RNAs so this is a good idea
of what the results this type of study
looks like so for example this is mick
which is
very reasonably short half a half-life
of around 33 then it's typical of a
transcription factor if we go to
something like like get head one which
is a another protein coding gene this is
a very very long half-life of around
twenty nine hours and finally here is an
example of a non-coding RNA which is a
half-life and save for hours so when we
take all this data collectively and we
put it together to see what does this
look like on a on a genome-wide basis we
end up with something that looks a bit
like this so although it's true that
overall along non-coding RNAs are less
stable than messenger RNAs we still see
that overall there is a dramatic
diversity in the stability of long
non-coding RNAs and that they don't have
a half-life that's really all that much
different to tennis enjoy RNAs which
again is sort of builds more support
that that these are transcripts are X in
fact regulated post-transcriptional E as
well as at the transcript level
suggesting that they might be well be
functional so I guess the next logical
thing to move on to is is what sort of
harm what sort of expression do we
actually seen in these transcripts and
what sort of functions do we see so
there are many ideas about the different
functions and this is a and it seems in
fact that every non-coding RNA that's
been characterized seems to have a
slightly different functional different
mechanism so long non-coding RNA is
nothing like micro RNAs which have a
very distinct to a specific expression
profile and in fact sorry a very
distinct functional mechanism through
which they operate so for instance a
micro RNA which bison three prime utr
going to in that way lead to the
degradation of their transcript long
non-coding RNA don't seem to fulfill
versatile so the first example of a
function of a non-coding RNA has been
expressed so all of these have been
described as a decoy which is a
reasonably Sevilla trivial and simple
way of thinking about this so as the
illustration indicates we normally see
that proteins will interact with the DNA
double helix but similarly an RNA can
also assume a very similar form to DNA
and in doing so can also attract
turbines to two transcription factors or
other DNA binding proteins as a sort of
a mechanism to act as perhaps as a
sponge or as a decoy to affect the
numbers of protein coding gene a number
of proteins that are affecting to DNA so
sort of like a dosage response mechanism
as a second method is to serve as a
scaffold so because I Rene is it's got a
huge capability to be able to bind very
specifically to different proteins it
can in that way also serve very
effectively as a scaffold and in that
way bring different proteins into close
proximity specting almost like as a
chaperone type role in a further example
it's been recently described or over the
last couple of years is that in fact
they can also aid as a as part of the
mechanism to service enhancers so much
all enhances if not all enhancers are
transcribed as as non-coding RNAs and
the existing model that we have now is
that these non-coding RNAs then interact
as they're expressed from the answer
with other proteins which then serve to
alter the 3d structure of the genome to
bring to bring proteins into proximity
for expression and as a last example
which is perhaps the most tantalizing
and interesting today tis is where
non-coding RNAs can infect function as a
guide so in this sense proteins use
specifically binds to DNA and sorry
start that again so in this example what
we way that the the non-coding RNA works
is by it is by forming a very specific
base period interaction with the DNA and
in doing so is actually recruiting
proteins to the to that location on the
to the DNA so this is especially
relevant where we think about proteins
that have got a very generic role but
need to be recruited to very specific
places in there in the genome so this is
perhaps best to provide by chromatin
modification enzymes so if we think
about this about the dramatic number
of different chromatin modifications
that we see around the genome and there
is something like a round 150 or so that
have now be described although each of
these is these modifications is
catalyzed by a different catalyzed by a
different enzyme we have to remember
that each of these these locations that
are on the genome where these
modifications occur is incredibly
specific and have to happen in very
specific times in very specific places
so this is just a zoom in of that too so
you can see the detail of this but these
are histone tails and showing all the
different chemical modifications that
can occur to them and if we think about
the tremendous complexity of this and
how this can happen over a substrate of
some three billion or so base pairs of
DNA and it gets very specific
modifications occurring in very specific
times and places we need to think about
how can that possibly be catalyzed what
brings these things there so the theory
is now perhaps that that non-coding RNAs
are in fact themselves being used as a
mechanism to recruit this generic
chromatin modifying machinery to very
specific locations in the genome so
there's a number of examples of this now
that have been described in the
literature the first and most iconic of
these would be is the link RNA hot here
which recruits the polycomb repressive
complex from the which is extra so hot
here itself has expressed from the
hottest ilos i recruits pcr to and to
the to the hawks to the hawks below site
which is really a remarkable and
extremely interesting mechanism i think
i got there like and then within our own
work we also described the expression of
the Hawks b56 antisense RNA or EV x 1
anti-sense which seems to recruit MLL
one back to the to the to the hawks
bello sai so these are intriguing
mechanism so an email one is a histone
digital transfer eyes so we anticipate
that there are many more of these
functions and in fact when you do a Coco
Mia no precipitation with Pia prc2 and
sequence the RNA so a so-called ripstik
experiment you some
700 RNAs were identified twenty twenty
percent of soul which were linked rnase
that actually Co precipitated with prc2
which really supports this idea that
non-coding RNAs are bringing are
bringing this generic machinery to
specific closer so i think that the
conclusion perhaps that we can start to
draw from this and as we grow more and
more examples of functional load of
non-coding rnas it becomes hard to
distinguish perhaps what the difference
is between a gene traditional protein
coding genius we think of it and a
non-coding RNA and we for some time now
but forward the notion that non-coding
rnas can in every way be considered as
genes they functionally regulate and an
effect the feeder type of an organism in
the very much the same way as gene does
so good perhaps we considered akin to a
transcription factor or indeed even a
[ __ ] genetic modifying factor so you
once we actually put long coding rnase
back onto this graph which i sewed at
the start of the top you'll see that the
the number of our elf long non-coding
RNA low side which as I said numbers to
somewhere between fifteen and twenty
thousand with current estimates and
annotations actually doubles the number
of protein coding genes and that our
graph now starts to resemble
suspiciously the initial experiments
that were done in the pre really in the
pre 1990s which he estimated some forty
thousand or so different RNAs in human
genome so perhaps this was more
insightful than was ever anticipated so
sorry so the next term the next thing I
want to move on to and listen in the
talk is how can we rule out that long
non-coding RNAs do in fact not and
certain themselves encode proteins and
this was the question that we were off
and asks and again had never been
addressed in any specific way so when we
think about a long non-coding RNA which
can often be in the they ranged sort of
arbitrarily really from 200 nucleotides
through through to several thousand
nucleotides and links it becomes
incredibly clear that these things can
actually just by chance alone be able to
encode a protein so that's exactly what
we see here so what this graph is
demonstrating is it's just taken if you
model
random nucleotides into transcripts of
various lengths and then work out how
long and authors by chance the reading
frame is by chance we actually find that
about 5% of and there's about fifty
percent chance of having an open reading
frame of more than 70 codons in a in a
transcript of 2,000 nucleotides so we
were there were a mini informatics sort
of methods that had sounds to be used to
see if you could predict you know how
how do these things actually change so
in terms of how are these is the
securing randomly or are these actually
proteins so this is where we introduced
proteomics to see if we could use this
as a mechanism to define as an empirical
approach to see whether or not
non-coding RNAs actually expressed
proteins so to do this we actually turn
into a public database known as the
pride database so the pride database
contains some millions of different
proteins and what we did is we combined
this database with the aluminum body
Atlas which at the time was the just a
couple of years ago perhaps by far the
most comprehensive description of the
human transcriptome so using deep
sequencing this this they looked at 16
different tissues with roughly 100
million or so reads each ah and what we
were able to do next was that we could
overlay the the peptide tags back on
onto this transcriptome and see what we
could find so to go through that is mode
of you we assemble the transcriptome
from these deeper and a secret issues
the deep rna-seq data across the 16
tissues and we map the peptide fragments
back onto it okay I mean when you are
able to do that it's been incredibly
instructor because it tells you exactly
what the actual open reading frame is so
even though the proteomics will only
give you a very small amount of the
protein sequence it it gives you the
reading frame absolutely which
informatica lee can't can't be predicted
where it is the six possibilities for
every in the given given part of DNA so
from this are able to
reasonably confident Lee predicts the
open reading frame product which
transfers actually encode proteins so we
did this in we so from this RNA seek
database through a roughly thirty two
thousand long non-coding RNAs and about
of these about two thousand were indeed
protein coding so low sigh so and of
those about 700 actually had three or
more peptides maps so that's that gives
a level of confidence so there were
about two thousand that had two peptides
mapping and about seven hundred that had
three peptides napping so it was very
ten percent of of of the long non-coding
RNAs that have been annotated as
non-coding we're actually in fact
possibly just novel proteins that hadn't
been described previously in the study
we also identified another a number of
other proteins that had actually
occurred in quite unusual regions such
as an intron switch many of resembles
alternate Trent arm alternate
transcripts as well as pseudogenes which
were also interestingly translated in
some occasions so when you actually look
at this as a again on a genome-wide
scale we actually see a very interesting
pattern so the blue line just shows the
distribution of all sizes or open
reading frame sizes of all risk genes so
it's roughly what you'd expect that you
know you end up with a fairly broad
distribution between a hundred and seven
hundred or so amino acids if we look at
the red line these are the novel genes
that we identified using its proteomics
analysis and in fact what we see is a
huge spike at around about 100 and 120
codon level and this was these these
spikes actually coincide exactly with
where the where the human genome
annotators had hit on their own cut-offs
so there was an arbitrary cutoff of 100
amino acids where it was like if the
open reading frame less than 100 mean
Isis then we gonna call it a protein if
it's more than we call it a protein so
what does empirical you by bringing this
data and were actually able to infer
matically predict these other largely
small novel proteins and in fact many of
these will only have specific tissue
specific and also many hits accretion
signals studies where really had all the
hallmarks
of a functional proteins so this was an
interesting analysis when we bring this
data together with the new
transcriptomic data back to this graph
we again actually see quite intriguingly
that the the number of of jeans and the
genome continues to rise and that now
the number perhaps tarts they look more
like around 50,000 which is quite
interesting when we start seeing growth
again and the number of protein coding
genes when we start to look deeper and
when we start to bring together
different data sets of information so
having said all this at least at this at
this time it sounds as we sort of
satisfies the question we'll look if
these things are genes and they had this
this dramatic repertoire of functions
then surely we might anticipate as well
that that these non-coding RNAs should
also be involved in disease if they'd
sold elderly considered in this context
now although it during increasing
numbers of papers again as I said it
they're very much similar to the the
start of this talk there were individual
examples that seemed to indicate it
involved with a long non-coding RNA
rnase and disease but i wouldn't even
looked at the sauna genome wide scale so
there were examples where they were
involved in alzheimer's disease breast
cancer melanoma in you name it and in
fact by this time about 400 or so
non-coding RNAs have been described in
trees had been prescribed a specific
function but what we were wondering is
just how many more were there how many
more non-coding RNAs were actually
involved in disease could these be
therapeutic targets for different
diagnostic markers that were confused
for disease at a similar time these a
number of papers had had started to be
described looking at gos G well study so
over the last sort of six or seven years
roughly in the order of almost 2,000 g
bar studies have been undertaken on a
know this number of different diseases
so for those of you not familiar a
Jewess study is essentially where you
take typically complex diseases you take
a use a genotyping snip array to look at
at the presence of of particular signal
you type polymorphisms across two
populations of
a disease in a control and then you look
for enrichment of particular genotypes
or particular polymorphisms and you end
up with plots like it or like what you
see there on the right is so called
Manhattan plots where you get an
association of a snap in a region of
Regina and then people would be from
there go hunting to see what does this
what it was mean now the curious
observation that comes when you actually
bring all of these studies together as
in fact that there are that there are
that of these thousands of studies I
mean a very very small number actually
land and nonsynonymous coding regions
and only a very small number land within
the coding region of the gene at all and
in fact the vast vast majority of these
regions end up nowhere near protein
coding genes that can be within introns
where the entire liquid the circular
librium Brock is a long way away from an
exon and they can so they can also be
intergenic and we sort of ask the
question from our perspective could it
be that these were actually that these
diseases were in fact associated with
non-coding RNAs so the results are
typically interpreted that perhaps these
are you know non-coding DNA regulatory
elements but what about long non-coding
RNAs so that's what we sought to look at
next now interestingly the majority of
were a very large number of of
transcripts of long non-coding
transcripts are indeed lowly expressed
so in this plot which came from in code
first of all on the left you can see the
box and whisker plot showing the level
of expression in different tissues and
consistently across the board you will
always see that there are a far far
greater number of protein coding genes
that are that are highly expressed
across little tissues and that
non-coding RNAs are quite consistently
shown in blue there is having lower
expression and if we look on the panel
on the right what you'll see there is
that the number of so that shows the the
breadth of expression so this is the
number of the number of RNAs that are
expressed in a specific tissue type so
as you can see the fast the overwhelming
majority of long non-coding RNAs aureus
be expressed in in a very small number
of tissues and conversely shown in red
messenger RNAs are commonly
expressed in all tissues so this leads
to a problem when we use RNA sequencing
for example to try and identify and
characterize non non-coding RNAs so RNA
seek just by the nature and way that it
works is when you do a typical
experiment the most abundant one and a
half percent of transcripts take up
almost half of the reeds and these are
always exclusively a messenger RNAs
while only just one percent of reeds
measure the least of unen forty-four
percent of the detected transcripts so
if we keep in mind that the expression
of non-coding transcripts is very low
what we what we would typically see when
we when we do an RNA seek experiment
that we end up with a fairly scarce
coverage of RNA seek over long
non-coding transcripts especially if we
take a very specific tissue type sorry
if we take a tissue type that's got a
large degree of heterogeneity or a large
number of different term cell types in
it so this gives the idea that gives the
indication that if you don't take these
none of my genius preparations that it
gives the appearance of that these may
just be low background signals or just
artifact in fact that it may appear as
single tags for example and it's not
sure if these things are actually clear
so to increase the coverage of rare
transcripts you require an exponential
increase in read depth which becomes
incredibly expensive so to address this
we we try to consider how how we what
other methods might be possible to use
to be able to to assemble and quantify
rare transcripts and then together with
with John RINs lab and at Harvard we we
developed this method called RNA capture
seek so Aaron a CAPTCHA stick is
actually a very simple approach that
combines captured DNA capture technology
with next-generation sequencing so the
first step is that you simply very much
like an XR like a custom x over ray you
you design design an array that contains
probes that are targeted to the target
different regions
the genome you didn't take the RNA
sequencing library and put this over top
of the array and then transcripts of
interest are captured and the rest too
washed away so effectively what this
does it's kind of like you've almost
consider it as an anti exone where you
end up just capturing only the reasons
that you're interested in and you throw
a TL RNA and this is the only stuff that
you sequence so what this actually what
happened when we did this in our first
pilot experiment which was published
just two years ago now is that we we use
this to target a number of intergenic
regions in the in the in the human in
the Trent sorry so intergenic regions in
the transcript don't see is there are
other actually transcripts arising from
these regions so what the suit across
plot shows is each of those segments is
a different region of the genome that we
targeted some of these reasons were
actually protein coding but the vast
majority were entertaining what this
shows is the other preassemble trailer
pre-pre capture RNA seek over the same
samples and as you can see you only see
a very small number of splice junctions
as indicated by those loops when we need
to capture sick was the a really was
worth quite a sort of a Eureka moment
where we saw there was this remarkable
number of novel transcripts and splice
junctions that were identified through
this process and effect even in protein
coding low sigh they were absolutely
transformed into its these very long and
complex interlaced transcripts that we
saw so for example slides come out funny
but you can still see here the in the in
the icon above a very small number of of
what's normally annotated and then when
we use capture CQC this dramatic
increase in numbers of splice junctions
that are identifiable so when we look
back to to a protein coding region such
something incredibly well studied like
the hawk slow site it's a very curious
observation that kids made so on the top
panel there and a you can see
the existing gene annotations of ox
bellows I and riff seek what's shown
underneath it and in the bottom half of
that panel na are all the novel
transcripts that we identified just in
the Hawks low site alone the vast
majority of which some 100 almost eighty
nine straight 89 novel transcripts and
19 novel isoforms in just that region
alone see there's a tremendous amount of
discovery you can see there and be below
is what you actually see in a wiggle
plot and the genome browser in terms of
the depths of reeds so in green is
showing the tag mapping by conventional
RNA seek where you get maybe 19 tags and
in the lower using capture seek you
amplify this by almost 10,000 folder
more than ten thousand fold coverage
over that same region so back to our
question about disease it seemed now
that this was a and an optimal an
optimal technique or method in which we
were able to use this to actually
investigate these these these gos
deliberately linkage blocks to try and
investigate where they're actually
non-coding RNA is being expressed from
these regions of the genome so we
designed an array that captured about 50
bigger basis of the genome and all of
these reasons were completely non-coding
variants genic or wrench running so in
total these actually identities these
target at some 150 different regions oh
sorry 150 different traits and diseases
across 339 or so regions so our large
numbers of diseases we just put them all
together and then we just used the total
RNA as a from from a pool a pool Darren
a source to look at whether or not we
could identify whether there were
transcripts Express from these regions
so first of all the experiment worked
very well so we had a very large capture
source here of some 50 50 mega base
region so as you can see pre capture
over this region this is post capture
you get up with about a 336 fold
enrichment of expression so effectively
what that means is that for every tag
that you would have gotten in one of
these regions with conventional RNA seek
you've got 336
when we used capture sig so it gives a
vast and absolutely huge boost in the
signal so in summary what we found in
the study was that we identified in fact
about fifteen hundred or so completely
nozzle transcripts in these intergenic
do ours regions so compared to just a
hundreds that were that were
identifiable pre capture so the majority
of these transcripts were completely
novel and or where they're novel
non-coding RNA genes or they're
identified as novel exons of distant
genes so in the majority were also
something so so does this look like so
when we actually zoom in on one of these
regions we can examine what we see so
what we see there at the top of this
browser representation are the haplotype
blocks that were Charlie targeted and
you can see there the green lines were
to the g-word snips so then when we
reveal the the transcripts that were
actually expressed from those regions
this is what they look like so improve
these studies like gin code sorry in the
annotations and gin code and the
non-coding RNAs to identified in other
studies for non-coding RNAs you can see
this very scarce transcripts and and
this capture sequin and in fact others
it brings these these sort of occasional
exons that were lying around the place
and it brings them all together and we
can actually start to now simple things
that really look like jeans and look
like complete transcripts that can be
fully assembled so this particular
region was was associated with prostate
cancer and a large number of different
studies and a very very high p value and
would seem that these non-coding RNAs
might be very very interesting targets
to pursue in terms of what what causes
this the the difference in etiology or
susceptibility to prostate cancer that
was associated with those gy studies so
the slide here is mr. a so this was
another example where against shorts
happened to the graphics here but what
what what that's representing is the is
again a large
of a better that's a slip in a liquid
because this equilibrium block and these
these simple transcripts that we see
below that worthy supposed to be the
encode tracks that show that there's not
much else express their so these are
being messed up in the conversion
process somehow but again here we can
see a snap and the tracks below there is
the M coatracks shown in green which has
always no transcription at all and then
we look at the transcription that's
revealed through cufflinks after we
identify these using RNA capture seek
and we see the dramatic number of novel
transcripts in these regions so this to
summarize the data of the 339 target
regions about 200 90s that will contain
spliced transcripts so it was about
eighty-six percent of the region's we
looked at we actually found
transcription and in these cases about
fifty four percent of the carrot of the
captured area where in fact covered by
supplies transcription so if we go back
finally now to our graph and we look at
our technologies and if we think if we
take into account now a technology like
capture seek which identifies this
dramatically larger number of of new
transcripts in the human genome the
graph starts to look by different and
there perhaps we can now start to hear
back towards those lofty gene counts at
me and then in the ballpark of a hundred
thousand so I think this is an
interesting illustration of how things
change miss time and how different
technologies and different theories and
ideas can really influence the way that
we perceive the genome and and how we
think about this so I'll close down with
the summary so together we can see that
new technologies have provided an
increasingly complex picture I've asked
a couple of more complex repertoire of
of the human transcriptome that reveals
thousands of novel transcripts and
isoforms each of which show highly
regulated expression long non-coding RNA
should should in every way really be
considered as genes they function
similarly and regulated similarly and
can affect phenotype in disease in
similar ways long non-coding RNAs are
shown remarkably
temporal and spatial a specific
expressed which is perhaps at least
provide some explanation as to how these
were considered or seen previously in
earlier studies and and how they were
perhaps overlooked for so many years and
hasn't really been until new
technologies such as transcriptomic
sequencing and now and I kept a secret
thing where it's become possible to
actually identify these transcripts and
see what they really do just also want
to mention that our own a capture
seekers a of a remarkably interesting
technology that we see is as becoming a
pivotal component in in the study of of
RNA and its expression from the genome
so you could very much make this analogy
of looking at the night sky in the
evening where we might take a little
you're in a city where there's a lot of
background light you may look up into
the sky and see that's just a handful of
stars when we use a when you use a
telescope such as the Hubble telescope
for example we see thousands and perhaps
millions and billions more stars and
this is very much the same way that we
felt when we first use the RNA capture
seek approach to look at at RNA
transcription so the as a closing remark
I just think that the the identification
and functional study of long non-coding
RNAs is key in this interpretation to
juelz and is it going to be and that
these transcripts may be incredibly
valuable and useful for understanding
the molecular basis of disease it is
just the very fact that they are so
specific and so particular in their
expression that they may may really hold
the keys in terms of being able to to be
those the those molecules that make
those first and we'll initial changes
between the cell type changes for
example into something that's associated
with disease or where the program starts
to go wrong and that these fine tuning
regulators are actually key in the
normal function of of complex life so
our function of acknowledgments the vast
majority of the capture seek work silly
the web web miss entirely done by
Michael Clarke and Joan Crawford at the
the Institute of Molecular bioscience
and turn versa
together with John medic I just stand is
actually speaking in parallel to meet
money and and the rest of the lab team
here at the garden Institute Rose no
budget also contributed to the
development of the capital city approach
and that's all thank you very much for
attending the session and I'm happy to
take any questions from here thank you
so we've got a question from Tammy at
the University of Toledo who asks if
some of these tissues are tip sorry if
some of these are tissue-specific is
there any correlation with the tissue
for which the long non-coding RNA is
expressed in the disease phenotype
that's a great question and the answer
is absolutely yes there is so we've just
come across so in our initial study of
most of the data that I displayed here
was done through a pilot study so we had
we had pulled RNA where the RNA was came
from you know 16 different tissues so we
couldn't tell where the RNA was coming
from what we've done now is in fact have
divided have repeated the experiment
where we done capture sick with 20
different tissues so we're able to
actually identify the source of that
tissue and so for instance we've seen
some some really nice examples now for
example where we've seen doulas regions
that were associated for example with
crohn's disease and we see very specific
expression of these and we'll stomach
and small intestine for example so we're
seeing more and more of this happening
we also just saw a prostate cancer low
side which was also specifically
expressed in the prostate long
non-coding RNA that was it's just a
fleece risking the prostate and things
like that so I do think that there's the
indication it's certainly not true
across the board but my anticipation is
that as we grow get more and more data
to show the specific where exactly where
and when these transcripts are expressed
will have Gore get a much better feeling
for those associations
so there's no other questions we can
have finished their
okay so there's no more questions I just
thank everyone again for attending and
we'll we'll move on from here thank you